and one of the things that i think you
and i uh have talked about in the past
and you've been doing a great job of is
uh not just reporting on and kind of
covering or analyzing existing metrics
but you've also been creating a number
of new metrics and one of those uh is
this idea of an illiquid supply floor so
describe what is the illiquid supply for
like how does it work and then tell us
what you're seeing in the chart
yeah this is something i created this
week with my uh my buddy matt he helped
me code because i can't code to save my
life um essentially what this is is it's
plan b stock to flow model but instead
of using circulating supply you're using
illiquid supply and so for anybody who's
not familiar
a liquid supply is defined as supply
held by entities who have very low
spending history so they take in a lot
of coins don't move many out and then uh
liquid supply is defined as entities who
are you know taking coins in but moving
a lot out
so those are like kind of the
speculators in the market and highly
liquid is probably like market pictures
those kind of entities but
the liquid guys are really the
long-term investors the the strong hands
that we we all like to uh you know joke
around about
and so essentially what this is trying
to do is create a floor based off of
bitcoin's uh real-time scarcity and so
you'll see like we've dipped briefly
below the model before like in mid 2017
very very briefly at the bottom of 2018
and also recently over summer we went
below but we never stayed below briefly
um and so although maybe you know this
model isn't perfect to the tick um you
also see like after 2013 we came back
down and retested the floor there
it has served as a good proxy um you
know for perhaps where you know
long-term holders have set that price
for we also see like um last year after
september we we retested the floor and
bounced right off of it into the bull
market so i think you know with this
being you know with this being said the
floor currently sits at thirty eight
thousand three hundred um when we had
that correction uh last week we came
back down to like thirty thousand thirty
nine thousand five hundred i believe so
it came pretty close to the floor um but
you know i think i think this is a good
uh area to to say you know
uh the
you know long-term holders have kind of
set the floor here and it's a good time
to kind of average and survives you know
38 39k is also a pretty strong technical
support level as well as you know you
see some bids set down there um so like
a little bit of um
confluence there but
yeah that that's that's essentially what
the model is trying to do is looking at
the behavior of these long-term
investors and trying to kind of estimate
where they've kind of set the floor at
yeah it's fantastic so great work on
that one uh supply shock ratios we've
been talking a bunch about this uh and
it looks like we've got kind of this
bullish divergence that's playing out
here so what are you seeing on this
right we have three different metrics
here um the blue one which
um you know i
talk about this one all the time this is
the uh a liquid supply ratio
essentially this is just capturing the
movement of coins from those liquid
entities
to the liquid entities so movement of
coins from from weak to strong hands
bob can you still hear me because i lost
you on my screen i i can still hear you
um can you see me
i can't see you but it doesn't matter
it's all good just keep going buddy
because i'm just going through it on my
screen anyway the the red line is the
movement of coins from uh highly liquid
to liquid entity so these are kind of
the intermediate term investors purple
line is you change supply shock ratio
movement coins from
well it's essentially a ratio of uh the
coins available to be bond actually just
that to the amount of coins that aren't
available to be bond exchanges and so
right now as you mentioned we have this
kind of bullish divergence um and this
is very similar to
the the divergence that we had in like
june or july i remember um you know very
vividly like being in hawaii and
me and me and my lady created this and i
did the episode i remember one week and
i was like in the hawaiian shirt when i
created the metric and this was back
when we were like you know
you know uh crypto twitter was just
completely you know desperate on in like
sentiment was garbage and i remember we
put this out and we were saying yeah
there's this divergence and we're
expecting some kind of supply shock to
play out people were like on chain is
hopium this is all nonsense and then we
had 10 straight up days um and it's
interesting because that divergence was
a little bit larger in terms of like how
long it took to play out and it was this
kind of slow grind up whereas now the
metrics almost had this impulse up while
prices kind of had an impulse down so i
find that interesting um just kind of
the
the slope of the divergence is different
um but yeah
going back it's hard to find any times
where where
price hasn't you know over time reacted
to to the underlying fundamentals
although sometimes it can take time to
play out as we saw in the summer
also like this was a good leading
indicator of the drawdown before uh you
know we moved out in may i didn't have
the metric at the time but you know if i
started to see similar behavior where
these metrics started to decline pretty
heavily then i return bearish uh but for
now you know as you see in the chart we
just have this a big impulse up while
prices is moving down so
you know expecting that to that
divergence to kind of play out in the
intermediate term um exchange flows have
looked uh slightly slightly bearish this
week you could say uh
4586 btc
in aggregate put down two exchanges
about 190 million dollars a lot of these
inflows came to binance especially on
monday and tuesday when we had some of
that de-risking behavior
but you know when you zoom out it you
know you have these little you know down
draws but overall you know we've been in
an uptrend since since mid-july but you
know if that changes then we'll be
tracking it so
what about wales it seems like whales
are just gobbling up every bitcoin they
possibly can find
so in this newsletter i tried to uh
focus on some of the more macro trends
and kind of zoom it out but uh so i
don't know the exact number that they
bought this week but you'll see you know
whales in in a general sense buy into
these early parts of the rallies you
know obviously because they're the big
buyers so they pretty much are the ones
that are initiating the rallies um and
then they also begin to trim their
moldings into strength as retail steps
in so you'll see they bought really
heavily between the two 2013 double
pumps they started buying into the bear
market after 2014
um started buying in you know the bottom
of 2018 moving into that little mini
2019 uh bull run
also after covet or right around covered
they started buying heavily and then
they started selling you know
into the peak in the second half of 2013
into the strength in 2017 they sold the
top in 2019 they also sold the top in in
earlier this year so following the you
know the behavior of whales has has been
a pretty decent strategy i would say um
and you know they've started buying
heavily since since mid-july and you're
seeing just continued accumulation from
them and then retail it seems like they
also are getting in the game as well
and this is once again you know very
very macro what you see is kind of in
the middle of these broader you know uh
you know uh bull run
20 2011 2013 double pumps 2017. um you
see these large upticks in the supply
held by retail so
what i'm doing here is taking all the
entities less than 10 btc and then
dividing that by overall circulating
supply so you're getting the portion of
supply held by the little guys
essentially and we call these guys the
minnows um and what you see is you know
since like mid to late uh feb or i'm
sorry mid to late uh may they've been
buying and kind of macro since you're
seeing that uptick that's similar to uh
previous cycles but it's not as the
slope isn't as steep um like if you look
at the chart you see these really steep
upticks so i find that interesting um
but yeah nonetheless you're seeing that
same behavior that you see in the middle
of each cycle from from these smaller
guys what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]